[Musik]
sechste kriegswoche sechste woche von
putins krieg gegen die ukraine und auch
heute wollen wir uns die aktuelle
militärische lage ansehen und dazu
werden wir erst mal einen blick zurück
werfen denn und so sieht es aus putin
lernt langsam aus seinen fehlern die er
gemacht hat die örtlich von kiew gemacht
hat wir beginnen unsere überblick heute
mit einer mit einer mit neuen aufnahmen
dieses mega konvois wir erinnern uns am
23 märz stand ein 64 kilometer langer
konvoi vor kirchen nördlich von kiew
etwa in diesem gebiet an der beller
russischen grenze und hat versucht
richtung kiel vorzudringen das hat
überhaupt nicht geklappt diese ganzen
fahrzeuge sind niemals in kiew
angekommen hunderte lkw fahrzeuge
und von diesen gibt es mittlerweile neue
aufnahmen noch mal kurz zur erinnerung
so sah das aus anfang märz wir erinnern
uns die maxa satelliten aufnahmen wie
haben sie damals besprochen 34 lkw
nebeneinander über viele kilometer
dieser konvoi kam weder vor noch zurück
sondern wurde eben aufgehalten weil die
spitze des konvois eben vor tief in den
städten european und mutter aufgehalten
wurde von der ukrainischen armee wir
haben jetzt neue aufnahmen von diesem
konto die ukraine hat das gebiet
zurückerobert und wir sehen hier
unfassbar das ist dieser konvoi ist
völlig zerstört links und rechts stehen
dieser lkw
wir können das mal kurz anhalten auf der
auf der rechten seite hier sehen wir
einen kamaz lkw hier mit nach vorne
gebeugten fahrerhaus auf der linken
seite sehen wir ein oral lkw auch mann
beide aus russischer produktion wir
gehen noch ein bisschen weiter hier ganz
gut zu sehen
ein mannschaftstransporter der
russischen national gerade mit diesem 4
drauf des sv was eben auch nochmal zeigt
ja das waren die kräfte sozusagen die
russischen kräfte die versucht haben
hier auf kiew vorzudringen dieser ganze
konvoi wurde mir aufgehalten kam ins
stocken und wurde dann nach und nach
zerstört weil er sich einfach nicht
bewegen konnte diesen riesigen fehler
hat putin vor kiew gemacht deshalb ist
die offensive oft auch gescheitert und
wir sehen jetzt dass er etwas anders
macht nämlich im osten des landes
gibt es eine neue offensive seit einigen
tagen dort geht er völlig anders vor und
versucht ihm genau diese fehler die er
begangen im norden der ukraine weshalb
er sich aus kiew aus sumy zurückziehen
musste eben in racky für hand und in
donetzk nicht zu wiederholen wir sehen
uns jetzt material an was von russischen
propagandisten veröffentlicht wurde aber
interessantes material was uns eben
zeigt wie dort die taktik jetzt aussieht
zu sehen ist jetzt hier ein russischer
konvoi der durch naki fährt er südlich
von prag in richtung donetzk vorstößt
und wir gucken uns das mal an und sehen
hier oben
erstmal hier vorne sie mir passieren und
gepanzerte fahrzeuge einmal hier von
russischen reportern mit einem z davor
ein militärfahrzeug auch panzer sind in
anderen aufnahmen zu sehen was wir hier
darüber haben und das ist eben neu ist
diese luftunterstützung wir haben also
nicht mehr einen konvoi der in gefahr
gerät von links oder rechts von
ukrainern einfach aufgehalten zu werden
oder mit panzerabwehrwaffen angegriffen
zu werden sondern wir haben überall um
diesen konvoi herum militärhubschrauber
der russen und zwar eher
kampfhubschrauber die eben dafür sorgen
dass links und rechts hier sich keiner
hinterhalte ereignen können wie wir sie
so oft gesehen haben im norden der
ukraine das da oben ein mi 8 wir gehen
aber nochmal weiter
und sehen dann gleich einen sehr
modernen mi 35 kampfhubschrauber der
russischen armee etwas moderneres
sozusagen hat die armee kaum um eben
dort ihre eigenen truppen zu schützen
jetzt sehen wir ihnen können wir kurz
anhalten wir sehen also links und rechts
ist er mit raketen bestückt das kann man
nur zeigen die also im fall der fälle
sozusagen von beiden seiten dann
schießen könnten sollten dort
ukrainische truppen zu sehen sein
gucken uns das ganze mal weiter an denn
es geht noch weiter es gibt nicht nur
hubschrauber hier sondern wir haben auch
von gestern neue aufnahmen die zeigen
dass erdkampfflugzeuge hier unterwegs
sind wir sehen sie hier das sind zwei
leichte kampfflugzeuge vom typ jak 130
die fliegen über die region luhansk und
wir sehen also dass es noch mal wieder
zu zeigen einmal das vordere flugzeug
hier einmal das hintere flugzeug hier
die fliegen sehr tief auf der einen
seite um eben nicht von ukrainern die
einige kilometer weiter wechselnd
gesehen zu werden und gleichzeitig sehen
wir wie sie diese flairs ab vorher an
das sind das sind wärme täuscht körper
die eben dem feind signalisieren sollen
ja hier bin ich und das sozusagen eine
feindliche luftabwehr dann diese
flugzeuge trifft und nicht erzeugt diese
flair
trifft und nicht die flugzeuge
auch diese aufnahmen sind von gestern
aus der region luhansk dort wo die
russische offensive sich bewegt und zum
schluss wollen wir uns angucken was
putin denn damit bezweckt wir sehen also
dass er vor stößt in donetzk in lohans
ankara aktiv überall und wir haben das
ganze mal
veranschaulicht nochmal hier die ukraine
und wir suchen jetzt einfach mal rein
besucher in diesen osten rein und sehen
uns an was ist jeder große russische
plan der ihm erfüllt werden soll und wir
gehen ein bisschen heran im norden wie
gesagt archiv hier sehen wir lohans
quito netz und wir sehen dass die russen
versuchen hier einen riesigen kessel
herzustellen ein kessel in dem sie die
gesamte sogenannte joint force ist
nämlich die armee die bereits seit 2014
hier die ja die kreml in version im
donbass update das die eingekesselt
werden soll das sind circa 30.000
soldaten dort stationiert sind auch die
besten und die aktivsten und die kampf
erfahrensten soldaten der ukrainer die
seit jahren hier gegen pro russischen
truppen kämpfen und die sollen ein
gezählt werden einmal vom norden dort
hat russland vor einigen tagen die stati
sie um eingenommen eine sehr
strategische statt die eben an
verschiedenen kreuzungen liegt von dort
aus gibt es einen vorstoß nach süden und
einmal haben wir im süden
von donetzk ihr die stadt mario pohl
weiterhin gekämpft wird aber hier haben
wir auch einen russischen vormarsch
versucht der bisher relativ relativ
wenig voran kommt aber auch dort
versucht man weiter vorzumarschieren
mit an bord wir haben eine riesige
militärmacht die von zwei seiten
versucht hier vorzudringen und fakten zu
schaffen im osten der ukraine was wir
aber auch haben haben wir mit den gelben
fallen hier signalisiert und ukrainische
gegenoffensive die immerhin gute
nachricht ist in den letzten zwei tagen
haben die russen hier keine
geländegewinne erzielt wir sehen aber
was wir eben gerade gezeigt haben putin
hat seine strategie geändert putin setzt
hier auf eine intensive kampagne von von
panzern von raketenwerfern von
luftfahrzeugen die eben anders als in
kiew hier den militärischen erfolg
erzielen sollen den putin sich wünscht
und den ihr das sagen immer mehr bis zur
sieges parade am 9 mai in moskau dann
auch verkünden möchte
[Musik]